[Music]
climate change has been considered
a middle-class issue when a community
is faced in survival mode there tends to
be
a gap as far as what you can actually do
these are the type of neighborhoods
that deal with higher asthma rates and
are considered frontline communities
they're closer to the incinerators
they're closer to the railroad tracks
however
they're left out of clean energy
crystal hansley is trying to expand the
reach of renewable energy
and address systematic imbalances in the
process
she's the first black woman to run a
company specializing in community solar
a fast-growing part of the industry that
she hopes will make it easier for
marginalised communities to go green
and see economic benefits in the process
my vision is to bring
solar to every city in the country
so cities like baltimore city will be
able to
be a part of that just transition across
the nation
solar is going to be fairly critical to
the overall
decarbonization goal it's one of the
cheapest
forms of clean energy around and costs
are steadily declining to really get a
sense of
how far solar has come you need to look
at it over the last sort of 10 years
in the early 2010s or so solar
electricity
it would cost you about 300 dollars per
megawatt hour
today you can get that electricity for
around 30 dollars a megawatt hour
and what has really driven that is a
sort of fall in the cost
of the solar panels manufacturing
efficiency has steadily improved
as well as the efficiency of the panel
those cost declines have turned solar
into a booming industry in recent years
in the u.s not even a pandemic could
stop 2020 from becoming a record year
for new installations
but those gains haven't been evenly
distributed
traditionally there have been barriers
that
precluded african american communities
or underrepresented communities
from accessing solar for a simple fact
that you needed to own a home
or have a 700 credit score to get a nice
interest rate on a solar loan
as a result many minorities are left out
of the savings that can come with
switching to solar
now a new type of solar business is
looking to solve that problem
community solar is a model in which
anyone who might consider putting
solar on their roof but is not able to
do so for whatever purposes
signs up to receive a share of the
electricity
from a larger project so community solar
is an approach that lets everybody
participate in the benefits of solar
tom hunt's company pivot energy is based
in denver colorado
and has deployed around 50 megawatts of
solar across the country
you know that might serve something
between 5 000 and 10 000 customers total
he estimates at least half of their
business is in community solar
it's growing very fast for us i would
guess in 2021 we might deploy
double the amount of community solar
that we deployed in 2020.
community solar started right here in
colorado actually back in about 2010 or
so
colorado is a great place obviously to
develop solar we have
lots of sunshine here but even more so
you have a
really strong foundation of experts in
the technology
and the commercialization of solar a lot
of that i think comes from having the
national renewable energy laboratory
here
they're out in golden and have been
around for decades and so
i think that's uh set a really strong
foundation to have the solar industry
grow here and then make an impact around
the world
we are at the site of one of pivot's
community solar gardens
on the outskirts of the denver metro
area
the subscribers are a nice mix of local
governments
just regular individuals that want to
participate and then a few
organizations that serve lower income
communities obviously we produce clean
energy
but with community solar we're also
engaging a wide
set of the community in participating in
that solution
from its origins in colorado community
solar started picking up steam in 2016
and it's since spread to nearly every
state
one up-and-coming hotspot is the greater
baltimore area
this farm on the city's outskirts built
in 2020
was developed by biff energy whose ceo
robert wallace is one of the few black
business owners in the solar industry
baltimore like every other city in my
opinion needs solar energy
it reduces the carbon footprint but it
also is an economic
engine our process involves using local
minority and women businesses
to help build the projects baltimore
baltimore's about two-thirds
african-american
i believe that solar energy like every
other industry should reflect
the communities in which it serves and
that is a smart business principle
i think it's the right thing to do and
the moral thing to do wallace says his
company has three community solar farms
currently serving the baltimore area
with another seven in the works
meanwhile crystal hansley of wesola is
working to make sure baltimore's poorest
residents can reap the benefits of
community solar
state subsidies allow low-income
residents to save up to 25
on their electric bill if they make the
switch so that's really huge
for folks who are still you know
struggling while we climb our way out of
this pandemic
but it's often easier said than done the
main challenges that's associated with
my role in the industry which is
managing and subscribing
customers for these type of solo
projects is the trust
folks typically do not believe that
those savings that you're promising will
exist
it's new no one's seen it before coupled
with they've been bamboozled and lied to
in the past
to overcome those barriers crystal
partners with local community leaders
such as reverend cleveland mason
who opened his church to crystal to make
her pitch to his congregation
are you doing right doing great i'm
always looking for something
that's going to benefit our people as
long as we can help our people
understand benefits like this that are
available to them
we're helping them to save money we're
helping them to
make their life a little bit easier but
covert has made those outreach efforts
more challenging
especially since low-income and elderly
residents are less likely to have
internet access
you know i'm still bringing people
online for worship services
but it's a process you know these people
are
uh just new to the technology
uh most of them are not doing something
different simply because they just
don't know and i think it's our job to
help make sure that they are aware
and hopefully improving their lifestyle
along the way
ultimately community solar is just one
part of the remarkable success story of
the solar industry
which has become an undeniable bright
spot in the fight against climate change
but it isn't yet clear how big a part
this new business model will play
in terms of the scale at which solar
more broadly
can grow a lot of the growth today is
actually coming
from like utility scale power plants
in terms of adding more clean energy to
the grid overall
those projects are definitely doing more
but community solar can definitely allow
more companies more people
to get access to sort of the benefits of
solar
you know my my company has begun doing
projects globally we just kicked off a
project
in the virgin islands we've we've done
we've marketed in west
africa and latin america these emerging
global markets
we have a a burgeoning middle class
i think the community solar model is the
perfect model
to accelerate the penetration of solar
in those markets
the solar industry is in a really strong
position
at this point solar is is just about the
cheapest form of energy possible for
electricity
for those of us who have been in the
industry for quite a while it's
something we knew we would get to but
had to fight
quite a bit to make it happen i expect
that
by the end of my working career solar
will be the largest
source of electricity in the united
states
it's cool and awesome like to say that
you
have a company that's not only fighting
climate change but also saving
low-income families money
my end goal is to be able to bring solar
to every single household in the country
that's my goal and i think it's
definitely viable and feasible
you